heavy smoke could be seen across the
valley this afternoon in fact you might
have seen it several cars caught fire at
a junkyard it happened in the Northeast
Valley near lamb and I-15 just after
noon today Clark County Fire Department
says when they arrived there were about
50 cars on fire right now crews are kind
of putting out some of those hot spots
keeping an eye on it and of course the
cause of that fire is under
investigation
Clark County Firefighter is also
investigating an early morning fire this
time it was over in the southwest part
of the valley a home under construction
caught fire around 4 30 near Valley View
and Pyle no other buildings were damaged
and no one was hurt